I sincerely just Lin trolled by palates
- I haven't used this bag for a long
time look at hello welcome to today
memory and I are going to Vegas for 24
hours so you're coming with us we're
speak on a panel at the NAB Convention
super cute convention acronym feels like
a candy that old people eat and we're
talking about camp Takota
and michael Goldfine will be there so
let's go to Vegas
sometimes we're very serious
but do you think that how many do you
think it would take to scare you psycho
if I take it over really rolls off the
tongue yeah okay so we just got into the
hotel room and they just want to give
you a quick little tour with this and
then here's a whole space so very
corporate masculine clean lines hi then
we have oh just a kitchen for the whole
dinner I will be preparing later this
evening and you might be like oh where's
the bed how do you sleep
is this a pullout maybe always pull out
but slam what hmm I'm living in an
apartment for less than 24 hours
well here's the best did it it did it
did the debt what okay I'll get in this
human trough make sense make sense make
sense makes sense make sense sense
Oh
oh you're on your way to the convention
center to speak on this panel and the
laureate the accountant said to me
before I got the car to know what the
bird necklace said to the fish I said no
what he said watch out what very
exciting smells like cigarette feet
oops just a Lana hi Lana's mom hi mom
no we're gonna cry tonight looks
huh
it's so phallic like farts out here when
Mel is it's so beautiful I just need to
capture all of it okay so beautiful
like look at all this organic natural
beauty I get all this beautiful this
reminds me of Los Angeles really
nostalgic
okay so Thunder from denim I do not have
a tonight but that's an arrogance
boom-boom-boom like she's at a
gynecologist appointment right now
maybe heart just got on this tram
without me
and now I have to leave take it off with
the tram it literally was like
a moment where the door shut and she's
oh god
Oh something terrible's happening she's
on the re-express and I'm not it's like
she's going to Hogwarts and I just have
to live here
okay well just some what to sit and wait
sit and wait everything's fine
literally Meru ran into the Train of the
door shut and we had won those moments
were reached hands to each other we
couldn't get to each other this is
incredibly zoomed in a terrible framing
but who's to judge that was terrifying
good morning hostages oh yeah look it
you can hear the sound of regret
happening as people wake up it's
beautiful
and what's more beautiful my room
service got you yay breakfast of
champions
bacon Oh me up coffee green juice
Bailey's this next bag said it was
happening yeah this is what's happening
I'm wearing a robe I've only recently
discovered the beauty of wearing the
robes that the tile rooms offer it's
really great now I'm going to discover
the beauty of putting bacon into my face
hole girl but I could never
and then
but thank you that's Instagram
okay really officially back from Vegas
and so much work to get done / I am so
sleepy
but one thing that I did want to tell
you guys about before this video came to
a conclusion is that we have new Camp
Toccoa merch yes and I have some of it
oh hi hello what do you think about the
merch wag your tail if you like it goose
do you like the new merch wag your tail
if you like it at all if you like
anything some of these PMSing we have
dead today it's a camp Takota shirt it
is light blue and green goose loves it
and my sandals hey I'm your dad on
vacation and a sweatshirt how exciting
is that goose loves it so much and we
also have another shirt set that says
I'm you're not worth the middle finger
and its really great to relocate but I
forgot speaking go-to kipped coated poem
if you are interested in any
and video mr. jolly old well folks I
have all the rules and rugs sit back
relax as I said earlier 44 minutes
Los Angeles sorry welcome aboard